day of our Workshop it's a lighter day
but definitely we've saved some of the
best till last so thank you for sticking
around
I'm very delighted now to introduce my
colleague John spies Jana is a professor
in operations information and Technology
at Stanford the business school with the
current DCC appointment also in
economics John Works basically on
everything so I think of him as an
attrition but he also works on mechanism
design statistical decision Theory today
he's going to tell us about regulation
or auditing so unpacking the Black Box
regulating algorithmic decisions please
join me in welcoming beyond space
foreign
ER is also at Central Business School
and Scott Nelson who's at booth and so
in this paper we're basically asking the
question how can we make progress on
economic Frameworks for regulating
algorithmic decisions that are taken
with complex machine learning tools in a
way that's kind of responsive to how
these tools are actually used in the
world
and the motivation very much is the
increased Reliance on prediction
algorithms in many high-stakes training
decisions so
um in many of those screening decisions
we may be worried that there are
incentive conflicts because between
those who develop or use the algorithm
and between
um and regulator who cares about the
implications of their use so just to
give you some examples as human medical
testing we have an insurance company
that may be worried that a hospital that
uses an algorithm to Target patients is
actually over testing in hiring an
employer May care about Equity
considerations of the job offers while
in Hiring Agency may not fully
incorporate that same goals for in
landing which is the case that I will
focus on today because this is the case
where we'll be able to show you some
data we may have a financial regulator
who worries about dispute impact or
model risks that are implied by a bank
bank's use of a credit scoring algorithm
in order to decide who credit to
and so the move to automated rules in
this case meaning that we're moving for
example from a loan officer deciding on
a case-by-case basis who should get
credit to an algorithm who does so
systematically on the one hand brings
with it a large opportunity which is
that in many cases we are now able to
describe the decision rules that are
used systematically because they're
mathematical objects that we can query
and we can analyze how they've been
constructed at the same time many of
these algorithms are actually so complex
that it's very hard for us to describe
them completely
and so that basically has spawned many
approaches to describing what algorithms
do that now are starting to be used in
cases like Financial underwriting in
order to describe algorithms
um so for example explainability tools
that try to turn this complex algorithm
into a simple description
and so in this paper what we are asking
is how we can effectively mitigate
incentive conflicts if Black Box
algorithms are too complex to be fully
described and we may have to rely on
some simplified descriptions of what
they do
and so specifically the starting point
to my investigation today is that the
complexity of algorithms means that
while there is this promise that we can
now describe what they do mathematically
there's actually a limitation because
the agents in our model and specifically
a regulator may not be fully able to
describe
um what this algorithm does because it's
simply represented by too many
parameters by too many different cases
to which it could be applied
and then there would be in this world a
first policy option that we consider a
first policy option would just be to say
let's just restrict whoever uses or
develops the algorithm to only giving us
algorithms that are so simple that we
can fully describe them so in a credit
score in case it could be we don't allow
you to use a neural network that is too
complex for us to describe we restrict
you to using some simple logistic
regression with 20 variables now I don't
think it's trivial to describe a
logistic regression with 20 variables
but at least there's a sense that now we
can inspect it and we can use our
experience to understand what this
function does in different cases that we
care about for example in a downturn in
the economy or how it treats different
people differently
a second policy option would be that we
instead require that the maker of the
algorithm provides some simple
description of this complex algorithm
that tells us about its first order
behavior and for example Identify some
key drivers so for illustration here are
basically Illustrated shap so one way of
saying we have this complex algorithm
can be Associated the main drivers can
we identify the main drivers of the
decisions we are taking and can we
quantify which of these drivers is how
important or which impact it has and
such diagnostic tools are very available
but you know from from an economic point
of view
um they are often based on mathematical
axioms like shaft for example being
based on shapley axioms that are not
necessarily have a clear connection to
an economic justification in a specific
case where we care about specific
outcomes and so what we're kind of
trying to do here is we're trying to ask
the question if I have an economic
objective if I care about certain
outcomes not occurring for example I
care about avoiding the split impact why
I care about avoiding excess risk in a
downturn then does this give us some
access to the question how we could
justify such explainers from an economic
point of view and could whether that
could help us to basically in a better
design of them
um so what what is our main approach
here so theoretically we want to make
precise and justify
um explanations of complex machine
learning machine learning models in a
principle agent model where
expandability is not an ended itself so
we're not just saying we need
expendability because we all want to be
able to explain but instead we see it as
a means to an end so we say there are
some policy objective and explaining or
describing the algorithm in simple ways
could help us to achieve that because it
increases the options of a regulator to
provide effective oversight
and so in and Status examples I will
show you as well as the data calibration
that I have for you today I will argue
that policies that simply X empty
restrict the function heavily for
example say you're only allowed to use
Simple logic models at least in the
applications we looked at are
inefficient relative to doing oversight
based on simple descriptions of the
algorithms that allow more flexibility
because I can now basically audit in a
way that is more responsive to whatever
state the world is in but that at the
same time the design of that audit
actually matters so specifically
auditing based on a simple
representation that is kind of a general
purpose
um representation that basically tries
to maximize the information I retain
about the algorithm is not necessarily
the best way of doing it because in a
delegation framework I care about very
specific aspects of the algorithm that
are relevant to the specific conflict of
interest between in this case the
principle and the make of the decision
uh the maker of the algorithm and that
we can improve outcomes by thinking
about which description of the algorithm
is most helpful because the description
is kind of does well on average is not
necessarily the one that I care most
about if I have a specific Target in
mind
we then empirically demonstrate that
those results matter in an application
to credit underwriting that I will go
over at the end of this talk
and then we also practically linked this
to a project we have with fin direct lab
which is ADC based think tank that tries
to understand how regulation applies and
has to evolve in the face of Innovations
in fintech landing that would allow us
to increase access to credit
um and with them we basically evaluated
a number of commercially available Tools
in this space and asked a question to
which degree candles commercially
available tools actually respond to
requests by regulators
so just want to connect us to literature
I won't be able to do justice to all the
areas
um because of course it's like working a
very interesting fast moving world so a
first literature that I'm mentioning
here because probably the one that's
closest to my previous work is one that
analyzes data analysis with constructs
of interest and application concerns or
more generally incentive conflicts when
it comes to data analysis and
algorithmic design where we may be
worried that basically the person
working with the data and either coming
up with an algorithm or maybe presenting
you with some evidence may not
necessarily have the same preferences
then we have worried that that
preference misalignment may lead to P
hacking may lead to inferences that are
not reliable or in the algorithmic
context may end up with algorithms that
are used in critical applications that
do not sufficiently Safeguard against
um safety concerns or fairness concerns
and so what do we do here we basically
apply the kind of principal agent
toolbox that is used in this kind of
more econ adjacent literature at to the
case where there is limitations in how
well we can describe what the agent does
with the data because the algorithm may
be too complex to be fully transparent
and there is a finest literature of
course on disclosure and supervision
that ask questions similar to the ones
we ask here for fintech landing
basically asking
um
which kind of disclosure do I require
from a bank how can I effectively
supervise lending and so what we connect
to here is basically saying okay now
let's
re-evaluate some of those questions in a
world where basically algorithms are
used but these algorithms are so complex
that I have limitations in understanding
them
then of course there's a very active
computer science that has shown
algorithmic expandability that has
proposed ways of describing models in
simpler ways but also pointed out
limitations in some of those
explanations so what do we want to
contribute in this direction we kind of
want to say let's not see explainability
as and it itself let's try to motivate
it by economic considerations and let's
think about what that implies for which
properties we require of explainers and
you know I'm going to present you with
one model in One Direction that I think
is limited because it talks about a
specific context and specific
considerations but I hope more generally
that this can contribute to us you know
understanding better which specific
properties of machine learning
algorithms but also of the explanations
we have of them kind of are required in
in specific high-stakes decisions where
our arguments kind of matters to design
it right and it's also what we see now
empirical evaluation like the eye
explainer tools that work pretty well
but they are usually those that are
targeted towards a specific application
and not necessarily general purpose ones
and that haven't been adjusted for
specific applications
all right so I'm now going to go
basically in a very stylized version of
our model in order to show you guys an
example but I also want to make sure
that if there are any questions or
comments you guys can stop me so as you
know somebody training economics I'm
very used to being constantly
interrupted and so don't hesitate to
shout at me
um kind of makes me feel
um yeah I mean a 12-minute talk
um okay so what is our main setup we
assume there is some agent that I will
call a firm so the firm is choosing a
prediction function so basically a
policy that gets applied to data and I'm
going to assume that it takes the the
utility that I want to maximize so the
goal I have takes a specific form I
basically assume that it takes the form
of an expectation of a distribution of
data with some outcome y some covariates
X and then the utility is going to be
determined by how my prediction function
f of x responds to the outcome Y and I'm
going to integrate that over a
distribution
um where in this specific case that I'm
going to focus on today for exposition
I'm going to more specifically assume
that that application and the
distribution is a distribution of credit
scoring data so why I think of repayment
like does somebody repay their loan X I
think of credit file data so have they
repaid their loan and the past what are
some things I know about the income and
maybe about whether they they own a home
and then I want to decide based on this
information how to score their credit
worthiness
and my utility is then going to express
how good I am at scoring their credit
worthiness so specifically I could think
of different utility functions I could
use here the one that is simplest to do
for me today in terms of the theory and
kind of just showing what we're doing
here is just assuming that we have a
mean squared error loss
so the better I am at guessing credit
worthiness in a mean squared error sense
um the better I am assuming here the
better end of the firm is doing but you
could also assume different losses you
could use a likelihood function in order
to express the quality of your credit
score or you could directly say well in
the end the lender who's a firm here may
actually just care about the profit they
make from lending and so maybe you want
to choose a utility where they get some
benefit from giving somebody a loan and
a loan being repaid
um when you pay some cost for giving
somebody a loan then the loan is not
getting repaid and I'm using this credit
score together with a cutoff to decide
um who should get credit so specifically
I'm assuming here in this model that
there is a
um that there is a cutoff and I'm saying
I'm giving everybody the credit whose
probability of repaying according to my
estimation is above a certain threshold
um and then if I give somebody credit
and they actually repay on the left here
I'm getting a benefit that is equivalent
to the interest rate they pay me or I
have a cost that is equivalent to kind
of the cost of me
um for going alone and then maybe having
to sell the loan to somebody at at a
lower cost who is then trying to get
that back yeah
yeah so I'm assuming basically that the
object of interest is a continuous
object You could argue that in some
applications only the zero ones will
matter the continuous version is more
easy for me to handle in the application
but yeah so I assume that even if my
goal is giving out credit I care about
the credit score the Practical reason
why I would why I think about this is
realistic is that it's not typically the
case that a credit score only matters at
one cutoff like you may get Driven
Credit different loan terms you may have
an option of credits that you offer to
somebody so I'm thinking that generally
has value in a good in a well-fitting
credit score not just around the kind of
cut off for giving you loans or not yeah
okay so your question is um don't I have
to optimize the Cardiff and the function
together
um absolutely I would argue that in this
formulation here I can implicitly do
that because I could just shift the
function
so in this kind of I would simply think
of I shift the credit score and I give
somebody a higher credit score if what I
really mean by that is that I give more
marginal people
um credit or I want to give people with
this characteristic that's a good
question
right and so I'm now assuming that the
firm receives a training signal so
basically I think of this is an
abstraction so I'm not going to
explicitly model kind of the statistics
of learning here
um and we can discuss you know where
there's maybe a shortcoming of a model
that is has a first order meta surface
order I'm simply assuming that the firm
receives a training signal which here is
assumed they simply learn about the
distribution of the data so that they're
able to solve this optimization problem
like in practice they would get a noisy
signal about that so here I'm actually
integrating that out I'm missing
conditioning on whatever they have and
then taking the expectation with respect
to that so in this case here I'm simply
assuming they learn about the joint
distribution of the covariance X and
repayment y
um but I also assume there's a regulator
um the regulator may also maximize
utility function but I assume crucially
that that utility function is different
and so just to give you the two examples
that I will mainly consider in my talk
today
so one example is that the firm
maximizes utility the regulator also
cares about dispute impact so the
regulator cares about basically people
being scored differently across groups
so in this very simple case I'm assuming
that the utility of the regulator is
reduced whenever
um one of the groups has a higher credit
score than the other now in principle we
may be interested in basically the
absolute value so we may be interested
in general in any difference no matter
whether it's in One Direction or the
other in applications where we know the
direction in which we are worried about
I think of this as basically a
lagrangian relaxation of a constrained
minimization problem so we are
formulating in this linear way because
it's easier to handle for us
mathematically but you could also think
instead of a preference that basically
says
I have a distaste for average
differences in credit scores between
groups
um you could also think of other
criteria that involve kind of the
um normalizing by some permissible
characteristics that I think like credit
scores are okay to vary between groups
by certain characteristics but not by
others for like Simplicity I'm assuming
the simple Criterion but here kind of
the question of does this map exactly to
the policy case matters a little bit so
this formulation basically says I'm
concerned whenever credit scores are
different between groups that's not
mechanically translating to different
approval rates at a given threshold
because for that it's only important
what the credit score differences are
around the cutoff for Simplicity I'm
assuming that I care about credit scores
overall here but I think this is clearly
a case where like the setting I have is
somewhat stylized here
um a second one a second important
consideration uh is our risk preferences
so I may be worried that basically the
firm is say risk neutral over different
states of the world they are maximize
their expected profit but that the
regulator actually cares about the
insure like the in this case Landing
industry not breaking down in a bad
state of the world and so the way that
our model is here I'm assuming that the
risk preference of the firm is just the
expected utility that averages over
different states of the world
but the risk preference of the regulator
is specifically to care about
um utility in the Lower State of the
world which in many cases you can think
of as the co-lenders rather than
averaging Over States I'm kind of con
I'm I'm trying to maximize the minimal
utility over a number of states so why
have you chosen those specific ones this
may look kind of like a very stylish
model and it turns out that like
basically the main some of the main
regulator concerns in financial
underwriting specifically are exactly
the fairness of decisions which is
sometimes seen as in this specific areas
this bit impact meaning how different do
I treat people and model risk management
which is concerned with the regulator
making sure that the lenders don't take
on access systematic risk because the
regulator is worried that the individual
company doesn't take basically
externalities into account where one
lender going under actually has effects
on the overall system and may lead to
basically breakdown in in the credit
Market
and there are other considerations that
are adjacent to explainability
um specifically there are considerations
around having to explain
adverse decisions so there is what I
call adverse action notices that are
required from lenders so when they turn
somebody down they have to explain why
that is I think it's also very amenable
to an analysis of expendability the kind
of utility functions we have in mind
today that wouldn't be a very good fit
for that so this is why I chose those
specific two areas of regulator concern
but you know because I also have two two
courses here from from Finance
um I just want to point out that these
maps to specific considerations that
exist in this market of course the model
that I have of them is very stylized but
I I think the mapping to the risk areas
is is relatively realistic
so I'm now going to focus on the second
so I I do think you know fairness is an
important consideration together with a
explainability
in a way I'm choosing a different
example just to show that I think these
insights are more genuine because
fairness brings up many questions about
which criteria we should Criterion we
should use so this is why here I'm
modeling this with risk preferences if
you look at the draft of the paper we
have up um we actually have an
application there to dispute impact as
well in the data but today I will talk
about different risk preferences
um okay so now let's go through the
steps of our model and specifically the
one big deviation we put in relative to
a standard model of Delegation and
regulation is that we assume that this
full function that the
um firm chooses is generally too complex
for the regulator to fully understand so
basically I can't write a rule as a
regulator that depends on the full
complexity of this function f
but instead I assume I only observe some
simple description
so I'm now going to go over like what I
see as a simple description today I'm
very happy you know for any feedback of
whether we think that this is a good
model
um so I'm assuming that the complex
function is mapped to a simple
explanation
for Simplicity I'm assuming that those
explanations
um are themselves taking the form of
functions from basically X to Y so they
are basically simple proxy models the
reason why I'm doing that I don't want
to end up with things like the fact that
you can describe you know two parameters
by one parameter if you just fold it
right into like the real line so I avoid
that by saying that we have projections
used that there's necessarily
information loss from our projection so
a few examples of what this could model
and the first one is the one I'm going
to use today so I can think of this as a
simple proxy model so for example let's
say I have a complex model but I want to
describe it with a simple linear
projection so my projection is going to
work by me selecting a set of covariates
so say I'm selecting some of the queries
I think are most important maybe do you
have a mortgage and did you default on
your credit card last year and then I'm
representing the complex model by a
linear projection onto that so I'm
simply giving you a linear projection on
those two covariates maybe an intercept
um and
um for the given kind of coverts that
I've chosen that is simple linear
mapping that projects uh onto a simpler
function space I could also think of
this as variable importances so I return
a list of variables or I could think of
this as an evaluation at only a few
points so basically I'm projecting a
function onto kind of just knowing a
fixed set of points because I can't
query it arbitrarily often so as a
regulator can only learn about a few
test points and now I'm thinking about
which are those test points I should
send you
but in any case
um the point here is that effectively
our assumption is that I cannot fully
understand the function I need some
description of it that is simpler and
that is going to generally lose
information I'm not going to be able to
preserve all the information
and now we're considering two very
specific kind of policy choices in this
framework
we either consider an anti-restriction
where I say one restrict one response to
this restriction could be well if I can
only understand a two-dimensional linear
projection of your thing I just tell you
that you're only allowed to use two
two-dimensional linear projections
because I don't know exactly what you're
doing and I can dictate which function
you're using
the alternative is that I leave the
function X anti-unstrained I'm telling
you can do whatever you want but then I
will tell you
um whether the symbol description you
have is compliant with my policy now of
course these are two extremes you could
think of things in between in practice
we have a bit of a hard time kind of
imagining very realistic things in
between because if you have very complex
constraints on the function space that
may itself be hard to enforce so we are
sticking with those two simple ones here
but you can think of these as two
extremes on a spectrum
so let me now kind of just give you a
very concrete example to show you what
is going on our model in an example
before I tell you a little bit about the
general results we have and then I want
to take enough time to apply to the data
which I think is most important or
interesting part
so okay so our game works in basically
four stages in the rule setting stage
the regulator sets the rule of the game
so this would in this case mean they say
oh are you allowed to use any model and
then a simple explanation or are you
only allowed to use Simple models and
what is the kind of explanation I
request from here
in a training stage The Firm learns the
relationship in the data so here I will
make this as simple as possible so my
complex model is simply going to be a
fully interacted model with two
variables that are binary so basically I
can fully describe my model by what it
does on four different combinations of
access and specifically just for
illustration I'm going to assume that
the two x variables are heavy defaulted
in the past this is my X1 variable and
the second one is do you have a home
equity loan of credit line of credit uh
home equity line of credit so basically
do you currently have credit
um on
um on some some home equity
and I'm going to assume that the firm
learns about this and then chooses a
credit score that can vary with those
two x's because my world is simple here
I'm assuming uh when X1 and X2 are
binary assuming this is a fully intact
linear regression just means that I'm
allowing for any mapping from the X to
the Y but it's just a convenient
representation of this
so what I assume here though is that
there is a state so this would be an s
that can be high or low and where the
specific relationship of those variables
and creditworthiness may actually vary
with whether the economic economy is in
a good state or in a bad state
and this the way that I've specifically
chosen this here is kind of an economic
story so just want to go over this I'm
assuming the economy can be in a high
state or low state in a high State the
probability of repayment generally is
going to be higher so that may move the
intercept here so high State generally
more people repay their loans or
probability of repayment is higher and
at the same time I think that there may
be a specific effect in a higher low
state with a home equity line of credit
so let me just tell you the story for
illustration in the end all is going to
matter here is that this gamma
parameters is higher or lower but the
story that I have in mind is something
like if you are in a good state of the
world then having a home equity line of
credit is actually a good sign about
your credit worthiness it means you have
some home equity that you can borrow
against so we like that if you're in a
bad state of the world in a bad economy
we may actually be worried because it
means that you already have credit on
some of your equity and so that may
actually push you to go under for
example the value of your underlying
asset
um goes down so that would be a typical
example where I would say okay you know
that's kind of a signal is very State
dependent like in some cases that means
something good in some cases means
something bad so we may reasonably
disagree between the land and the
regulator about whether it's a good idea
to give people with a harm equity line
of credit credit or not
um and so basically in this case maybe
the the lender would say yeah I want to
give credit based on that because you
know most of the times the world is good
so that's a good sign while the
regulator may say I'm really worried
about this because if the economy turns
bad if you give all the people with home
equity line of credits credit then
suddenly they all go under
systematically
okay so then we have an audit stage the
regulator performs an audit with limited
information about this function so
rather than seeing the full function I
assume that the audit um only is
depending on on limited um information
I'm going to go into detail um about
more on that and then the outcome stages
basically consequences and utilities are
realized here I should say to keep it
simple I'm just going to run with mean
squared error as my goal so my goal is
to basically estimate this probability
as well as possible means with air which
I think of as an approximation yeah are
you deploying it
[Music]
um so I I think when I write I've had I
that's kind of the final choice that
gets deployed and F is basically
something I have a preference over
um so sorry this would be a hat yeah
okay cool yeah sorry um that's just that
notation yeah
but the state of the world is known so
it is the firm allowed to use the state
of the world to actually choose the
coefficient um so I'm assuming that this
happens before so I choose my credit
scores before I know the state of the
world independent yeah so I should be
precisely right there's kind of two
pieces of information that we have
I assume that the firm learns about this
relationship
but it doesn't know whether there will
be in a high or low state so they can
learn about the fact that in a high set
it will be one thing and the law said it
will be the other but they won't know
yet which state we will be in next year
when people actually have to repay their
loans so they give them this year
so that's a good question yeah
great um so what is the main constraint
I put here and again like I should point
out that you know this is like the
easiest
um illustration because here I'm
basically assuming that this
four-dimensional object is too complex
so think of this is like the complex
neural network and instead the um the
regulator can only understand the low
dimensional explanation but here I'm
assuming is basically the projection on
an intercept and one covariate so I have
two covariates I can only understand the
projection to one of course there's a
bit of a gimmicky example
um in the example I will show you later
that we implemented like think of one of
them an xgboost on 500 variables and the
other a linear proxy model with five
variables okay
um so the main idea is that this
explanation is now lossy so it kind of
matters which explanation we use and of
course I've kind of constructed this
example in a way that this will matter
but the idea being that I could now have
this function on the left like
represented by four different values and
then I say well I projected either only
on X1 so only distinguish between X1 or
X2 or
um or only between 0 and 1 on X1 or on
x2 so only distinguish between 0 and 1
and X2 right
okay so just recapping so the firm
learns this relationship I've now you
know normalized all the covariances and
variances in a way that makes the math
here easy to check out yeah so how can
the regulator tell that the projection
is done faithfully uh so it's a great
question so you are basically asking a
question
you know if there's limited information
why do I know that this projection is
correct
um
I don't have a very convincing answer in
the sense that nothing in my model tells
you why this is the phase or not
processing assumption that we can kind
of verify that this simple explanation
is done in good faith or that there is a
mechanism to construct it some ways you
could ensure that is you could have a
basically an intermediary who is able to
query the function arbitrarily often
even if the regulator is technologically
constrained over this there's IP you
could think of protocols where we can
try to ensure that here and the the
honest answers I'm making is an
assumption and I think it's an it's a
bit of one of the open questions I see
with this framework is we're kind of
saying you can't learn everything about
the model
but there is something you can learn
about it that can be verified like how
do we justify this Gap or how does it
look in practice in miles it's a very
practical consideration because these
kind of different agents they already
happen even within one company like you
have somebody building an algorithm and
somebody else who wants to make sure
that the algorithm doesn't do crazy
things so even the the make up the other
even if I fit an algorithm
I can't fully understand the the
algorithm so I rely on a simple
explanation so I do think this already
happens in cases where we may not be
worried about this verifiability but I
do think it's a great question here what
happens if we have a 2d nefarious agent
who tries to basically send wrong
signals and things very related to some
recent research in explainability as
well like how can I send you an
explanation that make myself look good
and we are assuming that effectively the
mapping of the model to the explanation
is something where we can have design
choices over but those design choices
are known by The Regulators so they can
correctly interpret it that's a great
question thanks I have a related
question does it make sense to have the
firm choose uh which projection to do
since it knows the entire function
that's a great question as well so I'm
assuming here that it's the regulator
who can tell the firm which covariates
to project on and that's going to be an
important policy choice if it was the
firm choosing that I I think there's a
trade-off right like you think the firm
knows more about the distribution so it
knows better which things are
informative and not just what is
informative on average but at the same
time you would expect it to report those
things where we have alignment over so
now our model I'm pretty convinced that
if you allow that to happen we don't end
up with an improvement over some
baselines because the whole idea is that
we want to force the firm to report on
those things where we're misaligned over
um and that would knock it out but I
think it's a great question I think both
of those point in directions that we are
not fully capturing with this model but
we hope would be a kind of interesting
questions to to work on based on just
this viewers kind of seeing it within a
principal agent framework
I'm great so
um
here I'm assuming that we have a firm
who cares about mean squared error and a
regulate who cares about mean spread
error only in the low case
so this is like deliberately a very
simple model so they are not no big
surprises in what the kind of
preferences look like the firm would
love to Simply use the coefficients that
are the average coefficients across bad
and good States in this model the
regulator would prefer the coefficients
from the low world and both agree that
the coefficients that don't vary should
be used
um so what is the first thing we could
do we could simply say let's just let
the firm do whatever it wants to do and
we don't do any regulation
so in this case this would lead to
basically the firm choosing everything
which means that we have a large
misalignment and we have a maximal
distortion of the choice because it is
only geared towards the average case not
towards the low State case
we could also anti-restrict the company
and say you can only use a simple
function that only depends on a single
covariate so here we've chosen the
covariate so that the X1 covariate is
kind of more informative about the
overall fit so in this case we would
force the company to say you only
allowed to use a simple function of X1
but because it's simple I can force you
to do whatever I want you to do
so therefore you're using actually my
value of The Intercept but then we are
not actually flexible enough to capture
well the variation between applicants by
um the other covariates which in this
case would be the home equity line of
credit so for example if the regulator
actually thinks that people with home
equity line of credit shouldn't get
credit we wouldn't be able to implement
that with this because the first order
important information still going to be
whether they're defaulted in the past or
not
so now let's think about different
explanations so if now the regulator
cannot process the fully complex one
they basically could use what I would
call a best prediction explainer so
that's the explainer that would say
let's try to describe the function in a
way that preserves as much information
as possible about the function
we've chosen this example in a way where
this one is going to be the regression
on X1
so past default by itself is going to be
best at describing variation in the
credit score and therefore if we use
what I would characterize as kind of a
stylized version of how we usually think
of explaining when we do it with purely
mathematical actions kind of saying what
are the variables that allow me to
describe most about the variation of the
function or that's equivalent to
basically saying I want to fit a simple
linear model that explains as much of
the variation so for example I could run
a lasso in order to do that and then say
okay now I have a simple description of
this complex function that preserves as
much as possible about a prediction so
here what happens well it solves some of
the problem it solves the problem that
we disagree about the overall level of
risk it doesn't solve the problem that
we disagree about the use of this HELOC
variable because that is not visible to
this explainer because this explainer
doesn't see variation by that second
variable
of course we could have done the
opposite we could have said well why
don't we instead ask the firm to report
how much it varies by X2 now of course
I've written this example so that this
exactly gives us the best solution here
so what is the idea here well I'm now
explaining the part of the function that
we disagree over I knew that we didn't
really disagree about giving people
credit based on whether they have
default in the past or not but I know
that we disagree over whether
um they got a home equity line of credit
so let me choose an explanation where
this is the main information I get about
your function
um and so um in this case that can
achieve the first best because it would
mean that I'm basically exactly forcing
you to choose the covariance that I care
about while letting you choose the ones
um that we agree on
right so that's the main idea so what's
going to be ideal when I put this in in
larger Frameworks so we have a very
complex model so think of as a neural
network which you have represented by
this full square of four things but now
because I'm describing that in a simple
way
different ways of doing that are not
going to be the same the moment that I
lose information by definition
um I will have a choice which
information I preserve and so my
argument is just that in an economic
framework that may actually matter for
practice okay
so what I want to do in in the last um
10 15 minutes is I first want to just
sketch out how we think of this model in
general like Beyond a simple example
and I then want to show you guys an
empirical application we have a few
pictures that argue that that trade-off
between basically constraints and
flexibility and in the imperative
station we have actually it builds on
the side of it it makes sense to allow
firms flexibility yeah
um what if there is correlations between
those covariates so that's a great
question so I have basically rigged this
example so that there aren't right so
that
um if I basically restrict
um for example if I if I learn about
um X1 I'm not also a constraining X2 the
optimal solution here would take uh like
here I just don't have any interactions
because the kind of the distribution
here is um is chosen so that it's
independent
um in general that consideration would
be important so for example you could
you could be in a case where you say I
care about those two variables which are
related to my misalignment but there's
maybe one proxy variable that is pretty
good at capturing the effect of both of
them so there may be an opportunity it
may also make it harder for you to
design the optimal explainer the general
results We have basically tell you you
know in those cases what is the
prediction problem you solve
uh in basically maximizing
informativeness taking the covariant
interaction into account but here the
reason why this doesn't show up is
simply that I assume Independence
otherwise it would have shown up
okay
um okay so
um just want to
kind of point out a general model that
we're that we're writing down to tackle
this so the general model
um that that we are thinking about in
the background here is one where we have
misalign preferences
we assume they can be represented as
basically averaging a utility over a
covariate space where I'm choosing a
function that Maps those covariates
think of this as basically loss
functions relative to some optimal
credit score that is optimal for the
different uh for different agents but
then it may also be that the
distribution over the axis we care about
may also be different so maybe a bank
cares about customers in a certain area
but I'm worried that they're not working
particularly well for customers in a
different area
so that would incorporate things like a
covariate shift where the X distribution
changes between what the regulator cares
about the firm cares about a model shift
where basically the prediction Target
changes I care about basically a
differently shifted credit score or
would also include distributional
preferences where I care
um either about groups differently or
where I put some weight on equality
across groups and I would argue in two
slides that I can incorporate this year
and so then the general structure of the
delegation game is like before I
presented this as saying first The Firm
chooses and then the regulator audits of
course if the regulator has the ability
to punish arbitrarily harshly I can also
flip that around and just say the
regulator puts the constraint on the
functions you can choose and then the
company goes in and chooses among among
those functions so in a standard way
kind of in in the kind of more uh
economic side of
um of mechanism design here would be to
say this is a delegation game where the
regulator has some prior information
about the distribution chooses a
restrictions on the functions you can
choose the firm then has knowledge about
the state of the world and chooses from
that
um and then the main explanation
constraint is that this Con this
constraint can't be arbitrary the
constraint can only be based on simple
explanations so I can't put arbitrary
constraints on a function I can can't
tell you to choose a function as exactly
this function I can only tell you a
function that is within an equivalence
class where the equivalence class is
defined
um by my
explanation mapping
and then basically the interesting
policy choice in this General model are
when is it optimal to restrictive
functions to those that are perfectly
explained versus leaving them
unconstrained and if I constrain them
what is the optimal choice of this
explainer mapping within some class of
mappings
I just want to point out some general
results here so one isn't a big surprise
um because that has been pointed out
kind of Statistics side of things before
the fact that assume we're in a case
where we only care about different
distributions so the firm cares about
one distribution the regulator maybe is
particularly concerned about
increasing credit to another
distribution and then cares about this
function also working well on say
applicants that are not historically in
my credit files
so if in this case the two distributions
are the only thing that matters between
those two different utility functions
it's only distribution shift and if
basically the regulator one is
absolutely continuous with respect to
the firm one meaning I can learn from
The Firm one about the regulator one
then the choices are perfectly aligned
if I don't put any constraints because
for every person I still want to find a
credit score that works as well as
possible
um however if I constrain functions to
be simple now I have a problem of
fitting a mispecified function suddenly
there's misalignment because the um the
regulator wants a mispecified function
it works well for one group The Firm for
another so it's just a side note
um that actually in this case if we just
have a covariate shift and we don't take
statistical considerations into account
which may mean that it may be hard to
basically optimally estimate those
functions well for everybody at least
like from this point of view there is no
change in the optimal function so we
agree on the optimum function we just
want to give everybody credit to the
best of our knowledge and the fact that
the distribution of people already saw
is different from those I will see
doesn't change anything about that so
let me therefore now focus on the case
that I teased with the risk example so
this would be model shift so now the
distribution is the same
but the utilities can be different so
specifically let's think of this as I
have loss with respect to two different
targets and we disagree about the target
and then if I'm also further assuming
that as in the example I want to fix a
explainer by projecting onto a linear
model on a subset of the covariates with
a subset of the command is denoted by S
then basically what happens in practice
is the regulator effectively chooses
what those projected coefficients should
be and the firm with full knowledge of
the state then chooses the specific
prediction function among those that
have the right explanation
um and so in this case the interesting
General Insight is maybe first of all
the prediction explainer is different
from the optimal explainer we should be
using here the prediction explainer
minimizes the loss relative to the
Target
the targeted explainer turns out the one
that is optimal here in the sense of
maximizes the utility of the regulator
is actually the one that targets the
difference between those two functions
so I can hear basically formally write
that the best explainer is the one that
is best at predicting the difference
between the two Targets
and and what I mean by the Target
explainer here as I mean if I have a
choice of which covariance to choose so
I can tell the the regulator which
simple model to to produce then that
choice is exactly the subset so that
basically a linear fit
um to to the subset produces the lowest
loss
and so in general we can then show that
basically if the loss from this optimal
targeted explainer uh in being able to
predict the difference is smaller than
the loss I would get from just fitting a
simple linear model relative to my first
best then basically prediction explainer
is better than constraining x and two
I'm showing this very fast because the
idea is the same as an example and I
want to show the numbers later and but
that's kind of the idea of the model and
you just want to add a distributional
preferences if I write my distributional
preferences as utility average utility
minus a penalty for deviating between
the two groups then I can just rewrite
this as a model shift and kind of say
that's equivalent to utility where I put
some penalty on
um basically treating one group well
relative to another and here it turns
out that a Target explainer is going to
be exactly the explainer that um chooses
those variables that are most related to
group identities so in this case the
target explainer would be the explainer
that says I try to find the covariates
that are most indicative of being in one
group versus the other rather than I
choose the covariates that are most
indicative of whether you are high or
low credit webinars you could think of
extensions where basically the optimal
things would be combined both turns out
that in this simple model that's that's
already the optimal thing to do
but I know that this was like a very
fast run through kind of trying to tease
the fact that there's a general model
behind this what I want to do now for
the last five minutes is I just want to
show you this in action and specifically
we are now fitting this on a large
credit score data set so this is
basically a panel of 50 million people
of which we draw a sub sample this case
a sub-sample of around 400 000 people
that we work with
in this data set
um there is credit score information
about basically past financial behavior
so this would be the kind of things that
end up in your credit score I mean this
is basically a company that provides
credits courses exactly the same kind of
information
and then we observe um whether somebody
repaid a personal loan so specifically
in this case we think about credit card
loans so basically did you default on
your credit card or did you pay your
credit card down in time
there is a lot of missing outcomes here
so many people who we don't actually
observe whether they repaid maybe they
didn't get a credit card or maybe they
didn't apply for the specific product
and so there are many cases where I may
have new applicants
um that we don't observe the data for
and in our case that means we may have
training data where we don't know what
would happen to those so there's
uncertainty about what would happen to
those and here we're going to exploit
this in a stylized way we've got to
assume A variation where in a bad state
of the world those people who have
missing data wouldn't repay and in a
good state of the world those people
would repay a more sophisticated model
would be one where we use an imputation
for those people here for illustration
I'm just assuming the other repaying or
not and basically good State meaning
everybody we pay so I don't know about
currently that said means everybody
doesn't repay or don't know about and so
these are around 20 of our data
um the Baseline reject the Baseline
default rate here is around 12 percent
in this so that of course like moves the
ability forward rate by quite a bit but
those 20 payback or not
um and then I build a prediction
function for credit card default here
where I consider three different loss
functions let's first think about what
the firm would do
let's assume that the firm that isn't
audited just chooses a function that
minimizes average prediction loss
averaged over both states of the world
so here let's just assuming 80 of the
world these people are repay in 20 of
the world uh we're at a bad State and
they don't repay
the regulator only cares about the low
state so they only care about having a
credit score that still works well when
basically the economy is in a bad state
and the firm that is audited now still
solves the same goal that they have so
average quality because this is what
they care about for for their own goal
but now subject to the constraint that
the simple projection of their model
agrees with what the regulator wants
them to do so this gives the regulator
for example the ability to ensure that
the overall level of giving out loans is
not too high even in in their bad state
of the world now of course I should say
that this is um first of all this is
real data this is the kind of data that
a firm A lender would actually have to
take those decisions of course the
specific setting with high and low here
is stylized we also in a paper have one
um that specifically uh talks about
dispute impact so what we do here is our
explainers are linear proxy models on a
predetermined set of covariates we
implement this with linear regression or
gradient booster Tree on a total of 500
predictors if you look in the current
draft there we also have a version with
disbel impact where we fitted a neural
network and that optimization is a bit
uh complicated and we're still revising
this so I'm showing you this today
because the gradient booster trees and
linear regressions are giving us very
clean results that I can illustrate well
um okay so the last few minutes I'm just
going to show you pictures of this kind
and I know that this may be hard to see
from the back so I'm just going to talk
you through quickly
so we have here two utilities the high
State utility which is
um the negative mean squared error so I
want to be on the right here
um the high State utility is the
negative mean squared error in the high
State the low State utility is the
negative mean squared error in the low
state
so where do we want to be here
um so here we have a Pareto front here
between those two which is basically
achieved by unconstrained optimization
in this case of our X3 boost model
um where the oh sorry in this case I
should say this will be starting with
the linear regression okay in this case
of the unconstrained linear regression
model then we vary the preference so
down here would be somebody who only
cares about the high State utility The
Regulators top left only cares about the
utility in the bad state which is also
the the lower utility so it kind of
makes sense that there would be the risk
reverse the totally risk-averse Choice
The Firm here cares about an 80 20 split
so it's going to be somewhere in between
so the first thing we could do is we
constrain the
um firm to a simple model so in this
case simple model means that we're only
allowing the firm to use five covariates
rather than 500. so quite a dramatic
shift but I should say that there are a
few variables that are just very
important for credit card default so
that isn't actually as bad a reduction
but of course it actually means that
this simple model here is considerably
worse than the frontier in all states of
the world but the advantage would be the
regulator could now Force The Firm to
choose the point on the top left so of
course there would be an improvement
relative to letting the firm do whatever
it wants
so the second thing we do is like let's
say that we are constraining the firm uh
on a explained set of five covariates
and let's just start with saying we just
choose five covariates randomly and then
we say those five covariates the linear
projection has to be whatever the
regulator ones so we end up with
basically a new Pareto Frontier
so this is the frontier subject to the
constraint of course the regular is on
that because the regulator's model
fulfills the constraint but we don't get
particularly far out because
um the firm's model is very different
and then the ad solution is kind of up
here so even with this kind of randomly
chosen model we're already increasing
the low State utility to kind of a level
that the regulator likes better than the
simple model while not kind of hurting
the high cell utility as much
but the idea is that we now can do
better so we could use a model that
um in this case use the prediction
explainer so the first best prediction
information that describes the model
well and that gets closer to where the
regulator wants the model to be or we
could also use an additional model here
inside the somewhat frame kind of moving
further to the top left which is the
model that specifically targets the
source of misalignment so in terms of
going from nothing to that we kind of
now went from up here to here but with
the kind of simple regulator model we
would have been on a point
um the simple model would have been
Pareto dominated by that one in the
sense that it has considerably worse low
State utility but also considerably
worse um utility for for the firm so of
course you know this is somewhat status
because we're using five to make
illustration but at least it it shows
that that medicine we see similar
results for dispute impact and then the
same here holds true for XG boost so I
should say that I'm drawing here these
nice pictures in the training sample so
this is a view of the optimization
because out of sample these will just
not be as nice but we kind of checked in
the rank ordering holds true out of
sample as well and just pointing out
that if we use xgboost here rather than
linear regression we get this is not
very well drawn because it it rescales
the axes we considerably cut the loss
especially in this lower case here
um but but also in in the high State
here so we are considerably better so
this Pareto curve is considerably better
than the one we go with linear
regression something we see in general
that is actually returns to using more
complex functions on these credit data
sets because we can gain additional
information and then we do the same here
so we again see uh that those constrain
sets here lead to an improvement and so
basically here
um the second best solution of the
regulator with the targeted explainer
um is basically
um comparable to the first test with the
linear regression in terms of
performance
and okay so
um I do think I'm at time so let me just
summarize kind of the main ideas that I
presented today so I basically compare
different ways of constraining a firm
who may have preferences that are
different from that of a regulator
specifically I thought about the case of
a lender
um and um I consider different choices
where I consider NX anti-function
restrictions as limits limits complexity
in order to ensure alignment and I
showed that at least in our calibrations
here that is an option that usually
leads to far too much of an if
inefficiency I then considered best
prediction explainers that minimize the
overall info loss and that improve
things but not as much as trying to
construct a description of the model is
targeted towards the source of
misalignment
um I will skip this I will maybe like
make a comment here the context that we
try to connect this to is kind of
there's a lot of discussion about how
should we regulate algorithms well in a
typical discussion is about should we
maybe restrict inputs so we don't allow
people to use certain x's and their
General consensus in a kind of more
methodological literature that's
probably a bad idea because it may be
ineffective at avoiding say
discrimination it comes at a cost and
second it could actually even be
counterproductive because I don't allow
the the model to basically debias
existing data is that a push kind of
more from the economics so to say where
we should us do outcome based audits so
we just see what actually happens and we
regulate based on that but that is
limited in that in my eyes it doesn't
fully leverage the ability to describe a
function before it's actually deployed
so usually that they would have to wait
for the bad thing to happen and it often
does not allow for counter factual
evaluation so if something bad happens I
don't really know whether that was
because it was a bad algorithm or it was
because it was a bad state of world so
what we see this kind of in is like
discussing two intermediate things one
is restricting the model which you can
see of a more general form of
restricting inputs and which can be very
costly as I argued or one where I
basically regulate based on limited
information about the model based about
the model itself we are basically used
for example simple explanation or proxy
models in order to do some of that
um and in this case we can at least get
a second best solution and kind of just
one to add this as you know one option
to the list of things to think about
and so okay so to conclude what is the
opportunity challenge here so as we move
to automated rules we allow for uh
scrutinizing or systematically even
before they're actually getting deployed
other than a human decision maker where
often can only do that after and I can't
systematically scrutinize their decision
making but the complexity means that
we're also Limited in being able to do
so
um the broader context is that one
approach to this would be to explain
better but that many Notions of
expendability interability and
transparency that are very Central to
machine learning implementation and
often not kind of clearly motivated out
of an economic point of view and so we
wanted to approach this instead from a
means to an end rather than means in
itself approach and say how do they help
us if we have some policy goal in mind
so here we basically presented a
principal agent model of Regulation
where we added this complexity uh
description constraint and then give an
answer in terms of those targeted
explainers meaning description of the
model that are specific to the
application and then relate this to kind
of this broader agenda of understanding
Financial regulation how it should
evolve so thanks a lot for your
questions I'm happy to take a few more
if you have time
thank you so much I was wondering uh so
one alternative is to give the regulator
query access to the function do you
think that's stronger or weaker than
these explainability based so that's a
great point so I
I see it as related in the following two
ways like if you want to take on more
literally you could see a query axis as
saying a simple representation in the
form that I can only see a limited
number so if you think you have query
access but you can't query too often
maybe because there are concerns about
intellectual property or technical
considerations I think of the query
access it basically gives you a reduced
information about the model
um where you a simple representation of
that model is now only what it does on
those limited points so in that case I
could map it narrowly I think more
broadly there may be ways of thinking of
query access as maybe you can actually
construct different statistics about the
function that are not just individual
queries but maybe I can ask you to
calculate certain statistics I think of
all this as basically a process by which
I take a very complex functions and I'm
function and try to represent it by a
few numbers because a decision maker may
only care about those numbers or may not
be able to compute more of those or
because it's we can't Supply more
information in that without you know
some privacy concerns or something
concerns so in that sense I think it
still has the same structure that our
decision making is based on a simple set
of information
and then I would basically uh I would
see our model as trying to answer the
question or trying to frame the question
what pieces of information should that
be because maybe it's not just the
dispute impact on the existing data
because you're actually interested in
how the dispute impact will be on a
different draw of the data even once
you've seen the actual dispute impact
you may want to answer the question is
this because of a bad model or is this
because of a bad jaw like or a specific
draw of the applicants that have changed
in in unpredictable ways and so you may
still want to use information about your
model to make those calls and we're kind
of saying well in the moment that you
use this information but it can't be
everything at once you lose some
information and you gain some
information so which information are you
okay to lose and which do you want to
preserve
that would be my yep
all right thanks a lot for the great
talk uh just one kind of friend question
uh we are fixing the level of complexity
of the explainer right so like in your
example you need five you want that's
most five yeah covariants so uh any
comments on kind of comparative Statics
if you change that a little bit because
as you mentioned in many high
dimensional data sets at the end only a
few variables matter right I agree
um so
my sensors among financial data is that
there is a large concentration on a few
variables being the first order drivers
of either like say differences between
groups or of the main outcome of
Interest
but that there is still gain in using
the long tail in prediction so to me
that actually means that there is a way
of explaining it relatively well where
we can explain a large part of the
variation with a few variables but in
practice there is so much in detail that
we don't want to give up on that tail in
terms of prediction quality so just from
the financial companies I know there are
other contexts where you know maybe
there are basically simple models in the
set of models that are almost as good as
the best models my sense is that
for the specific context of the data we
look at it and the large sample sizes we
have here router to some
critical social science applications
where we not have the same amount of
sample that there is actually a benefit
to being
to using all the data and that that may
actually have Equity considerations as
well where if we only use some of the
standard measurements these may be those
that say minority applicants
traditionally don't have in their credit
file and that by using a long tail of
data or using non-standard data we can
actually increase credit access for
those people who are traditionally
unbanned so Laura Platinum Mike author
and Scott Nelson they have a paper where
they kind of make the argument that a
lot of the inequity in lending naturally
related to basically noise or missing
information
um on the X covariate side and so I I do
actually think that there are strong
reasons to think that we should still
squeeze out more information even if a
few are enough to describe them all
relatively well so this is why I think
we went in the specific Direction in
this data set I think that may not
generalize to all other critical
applications yes great thank you
the interest of time let's take the rest
of the questions during our break let's
thank you again
[Applause]